if your whole city was being invaded by
terrifying aliens what would you do
these monsters are killing everyone you
know and soon everyone in this country
will die I'm going to break down the
mistakes made what you should do and how
to beat the alien Army in parasite part
two this little twerp has no idea that
he is about to die high school student
shanichi here has had his life turned
upside down his body has been taken over
by this Rogue Alien Parasite called migi
and they have gone through hell to
survive the recent alien invasion
discovering that these monsters have
finally begun to infiltrate the
government the two discuss on how to
stop these parasites from taking over
the world before it's too late migi here
says that the aliens are trying to turn
this town into a safe haven for
parasites slowly but surely killing
humans and using their flesh to disguise
themselves as members of the government
which means it won't be long before they
take over the entire country however
shinichi has bigger High School problems
to deal with and he tells migi that
before they go after any monsters he
needs to reveal his parasite power
secret to one of the two girls that he
sorta likes since anyways he thinks
she's on to them he then goes to tell
this girl to meet him at this abandoned
warehouse and he prepares to tell her
his biggest secret but that was also his
biggest mistake shinichi's Crush arrives
at the warehouse but shinichi isn't
there yet hearing some noise around this
dark corner she happily thinks it's her
Bae but that's when she sees this
horrifying alien feasting on this human
corpse she runs for her life and gets
badly injured nearing the exit of the
building she tries to get away and see
shinichi show up just in time to watch
her get brutally stabbed through the
heart shinichi is horrified and
unleashes his inner alien Beast killing
this parasite right here and he watches
one of the two girls that he likes die
right in front of him well what did you
expect why would you take a girl that
you like to an abandoned warehouse yes
it was semi-public but what are you
doing this is horrifyingly stupid
shinichi's had a wild ride ever since
the Alien Invasion began and his lost
family members like his mother and has
seen friends for from his school get
brutally murdered in the process but
he's at a turning point now where the
stakes will matter more than they ever
have before and this girl's death is
proof of that because from the moment
the Alien Invasion began these parasites
had been killing and infecting humans
since they invaded Earth and have begun
to kill and infect every level of
society and government there is and
that's what makes this girl's death all
the more terrifying because just like
what migey tried to do and failed with
shinichi when they first met these
aliens up until now have tried to infect
people in secret entering their body as
smaller organisms and attaching
themselves to the human brain
effectively taking over the human of
their human host and their Consciousness
this is what migi tried and failed to do
with shinichi which caused shinichi to
have his Consciousness kept intact and
ended up forcing both of them to coexist
within each other however all of this
Alien Invasion stuff started like I said
in secret as in under the radar nobody
noticed but what happened to shinichi's
Bay over here happened in broad daylight
and as despite the attack happening in
an abandoned house this attack still
took place near the proximity of a busy
street and suburban houses as we can
tell from where this house resides why
would you do that why would you take a
girl to an abandoned house you all know
what this means right this means that
the alien invasion is at a Crossroads it
means that these monsters are getting
more and more confident in their
abilities to reside to near human
populations on a daily basis and still
pull off attacks which makes this a huge
problem for society as a whole and this
is the reason why shinichi shouldn't
have arranged a meeting in some place
that he wasn't familiar with and should
have met up with this girl in the most
obvious place that he could have taken
her to his house plus doing this could
have made it look like he was the stud
that she kind of wished he was and also
ever since shinichi merged with migi the
two have seen death left and right and
by the way have already drawn the
attention of the FBI and they've started
looking at shinichi this means that
inviting a high school girl to meeting
him at an abandoned warehouse was so
dumb and stupid to begin with the next
day the FBI I watch shinichi at school
they know about the recent alien
invasion and they think shinichi has
something to do with it elsewhere the
other parasites have come together to
discuss who or what killed one of their
own members and they began growing
concerned that the humans are learning
more and more about them too quickly
suddenly another Alien Parasite named
ryoko enters the room and reveals that
shinichi is likely the one who killed
their teammate and that his parasite is
coexisting with him inside his hand
ryoko is a low-key mad scientist and she
thinks that shinichi's unique bond with
his parasite makes him an amazing sample
and the group of parasites allow her to
investigate shinichi further later she
gets home and calls a local investigator
to begin looking into shinichi more but
this investigator has no idea that this
job will cost him his life that night
shinichi thinks about his Bae that he
lost I mean he's got a second one so why
is he so upset he thinks that because he
can't express his emotions like he used
to he's becoming more alien than human
but migi tells him to chill out
frustrated he go goes for a walk and
heads back to the warehouse where his
Crush died however the hired
investigator follows behind him in the
distance and he records the whole thing
inside shinichi blames himself for what
happened and gets mad at migi for being
so logical about everything suddenly
Mickey spots someone outside and charges
to go kill him he slaps the camera away
from the investigator's hand as he runs
for his life shanichi tries to stop migi
from killing the man and holds him back
long enough for the horrified
investigator to get away for good
shinichi has got to figure out a way to
control this guy this is insane migi
here by now has proven that he's willing
to kill anybody that tries to blow the
lid off of shinichi's terrifying alien
secret and this makes sense because even
in the case that there was no Alien
Invasion getting found out that you had
an Alien Parasite peacefully living
inside of your own body would be more
than enough grounds for any government
on Earth to chase you down to preview of
your rights and turn you into a lab rat
for years to come migi ensuring
shinichi's secret is being kept between
them is Paramount as the discovery of a
human alien hybrid peacefully coexisting
within each other will no doubt for some
government's hand to have us enforcibly
disappear because it means that certain
governments can and still do practice
making people disappear if they go
against some sort of nationalistic
status quo and even though this act ever
since 2002 has been declared a crime
against humanity it still happens in
dozens of countries worldwide however
Miki didn't need to act hastily as he
did because in actuality what shinichi
did was the smarter move because trying
to cover up another dead body the
investigator with an R proximity from
the last dead body we encountered would
have made shinichi look even more guilty
than he does right now especially since
the police already think that they have
something to do with all of these
murders and if we were to look at the
Optics of this situation from a bird's
eye view having a single investigator
whine to the police about what he saw
when he doesn't have video proof will
make his words worthless and while him
being an investigator might seem like
his word may carry some weight unlike
police detectives or crime time State
investigators private investigators
usually work for private citizens or
businesses rather than government
entities which means that him
approaching any police precinct and
complaining about shinichi's alien
problem will add to the cops not
believing a word out of his fat mouth
since without any concrete proof he's
just like any other investigator looking
for some clout since uncovering shocking
answers is a part of his job so in
reality migi has nothing to worry about
other than the fact that all of this
attention being drawn from the uptick
and parasite related human murders the
government will likely already be on the
case which means that these two can't
act as carelessly and be out of the open
as they are right now because one wrong
move just like this one is probably
going to cost them their entire lives
Miki loses energy and finally gives up
and shinichi angrily tells him that they
can take an innocent life no matter what
happens and they head back home the next
day migi goes through the investigator's
camera and he tells shinichi to be
careful from now on because if anyone
from the government enter the news finds
out about their secret they'll soon be
dead or Worse turned into a horrifying
lab rat experiment shinichi then begins
to worry that it won't be long either
before they get discovered by the public
or by the army of evil parasites and he
gets ready for the horrors that are soon
headed their way nervous about what
might happen to him soon he decides to
tell the second girl that he likes and
longtime friend satomi his parasite
secret before it's too late again is it
just me or am I experiencing Deja Vu he
meets up with her and she accuses him
also of acting all cold and callous and
having no emotion recently he tries to
tell her his parasite secret but chokes
at the last minute and decides to keep
her in the dark where he thinks she'll
be safe later shinigi decides to meet up
with his old friend big mouth to help
track down their investigator just like
shinichi Bigmouth and his Alien Parasite
have managed to coexist with one another
in one bot and they have agreed to help
him out again elsewhere the investigator
meets up with his client ryoko to tell
him of the alien Horrors that he saw the
invest Gator begins to freak out and
thinks that ryoko already knew about
shinichi's alien hand all along but she
ignores him and leaves but she has no
idea what Horrors this man is about to
commit the next day shinichi gets word
that big mouth and his Alien Parasite
have found the investigator and have
even managed to catch him taking him on
a drive in this car shinichi decides to
fill in the investigator on everything
that happened to shinichi since the day
that the Alien Invasion began and the
day that migi accidentally invaded
shinichi's hand they then find out from
the investigator that the person who
paid him to spy on shinichi and migi was
in fact ryoko the parasite who tried to
kill them earlier at shinichi's school
horrified and all of this the
investigator gives up on spying on them
for good later that night shinichi gets
a call from ryoko and she asks to meet
the following day the two meet up at
this rooftop shinichi then asks her what
the parasites of the government are
planning for the humans and ryoko he
reveals their insane plan she says that
the parasites in the government have
begun their plans to try Ai and coexist
with humans but doesn't know the full
story yet shinichi then asks her what
she plans to do with the human baby that
her host body recently gave birth to and
ryoka reveals to him that once the baby
is old enough she'll begin to commit
horrifying experiments on it to see if
it inherited any parasite Powers this
anger shinichi and he prepares to fight
her right here and now at ryoko dares
shinichi to make a move and uses her
baby as a human shield of meat but
suddenly they're interrupted by humans
nearby shinichi then gets away before he
loses his [ __ ] later that night shinichi
thinks of all the parasites that they've
killed since migi entered his hand and
then he suddenly has a terrible idea he
then tells Miki that they've won against
parasites in the past when he was just
one-on-one and somehow thinks that this
is a brilliant idea to have him and migi
take on all of Japan's parasite monsters
one by one and then maybe just maybe
they can stop The Invasion we need to
take a second to pause here and discuss
what just shinichi really said that is
insanely stupid we have to remember that
at the end of the day these aliens
despite their High intellect are animals
where it counts they haven't shown up to
Earth on a spaceship but came down
through the air for unknown reasons of
which they themselves don't even know
why and how they landed on Earth is
important because if they had shown up
on spaceships then this would have meant
that they would have had a super
Advanced civilization capable of
interstellar flight which also would
have likely made them capable of wiping
out Humanity since they would have been
technically Superior to humans to begin
with but since they showed up without a
real say in the whole thing this means
that at the end of the day they're just
like us scared animals bred to be good
at one thing replication and survival
this means that these parasites in order
to survive have probably by now formed
coalitions and groups in order to better
stand a chance at surviving and
coordinating their survival efforts with
multiple groups and what shinichi is
proposing is stupid as Hell by taking on
parasites one by one Rambo style this
ain't the movies that's not really gonna
work this is going to cause their
species as a whole to begin take notice
of shinichi and that means it won't be
long before their armies formally rained
down hell Upon Us in the thousands and
shinichi's army is an army of two at the
moment if shinichi wants to survive then
he should focus on finding more people
like big mouth someone who's just like
shinichi one who has been infected with
the parasite but still has retained
their individual Consciousness and will
and because shinichi has met someone
just like him it means that it's not
that improbable to think that there's
more people like shinichi and big mouth
out there that he could try to recruit
and build his own network Base building
a team to tackle this problem more
methodically would be better and could
serve them even better long term with
dealing with the parasite Invasion
shinichi could even try recruiting
full-on parasites and while dangerous
and Incredibly risky we have to remember
that at the end of the day their species
are not exactly evil they just exist and
are simply doing what they think is
necessary to survive but if we can
convince some of them to join our side
that it's going to help benefit their
survival in some way that we're going to
have a better shot at defeat the other
parasites in the long run fighting
parasites one-on-one like it's his job
which he's not even getting paid for is
the stupidest thing I've ever heard come
out of someone's mouth and I know this
for a fact because I work with the Dom's
big mouth for a living at the parasite
meeting the parasites say that since the
Alien Invasion began shinichi has been
killing too many of their kind and
they've now put a bounty on his head
later at school shinichi tries to make
nice with satomi and migi mentions that
he detects some parasites nearby
shinichi wanting revenge against the
parasites and finally fed up with them
gets a little too excited and runs off
to go fight them but that was his
biggest mistake migi prepares shinichi
on the battle plan but that's when he
realizes the most horrifying thing he's
nearly out of energy from the moment
that Miki restarted shinichi's weak puny
heart he now needs to recharge once a
day for four hours he tells shinichi
that while he's asleep shinichi won't be
able to use any of his alien powers and
he tells shinichi that all he can do
until migi wakes up is to run shinichi
then runs for his sweet ass life and
takes a train out of the the city ending
up in a small town but something is not
right and he sees a taxi pull up near
him and a strange man gets out pretty
boy then approaches shinichi but he can
tell that something is not right
thinking this person is a parasite
shinichi continues running and manages
to catch a ride deeper into the forest
but that's when he sees pretty boy right
on his tail just as migi finally wakes
up shocked migi tells shinichi that he
can sense that his parasite is more
horrifying than the rest and has
multiple parasites in one body prettyboy
launches another attack on shinichi as
he again runs for his life migi then
senses that pretty boy's tentacles are
all connected to one mind which means
that all of his extra arms and weapons
are useless if there's no head to
control it migi then tells shinichi to
stop in this spot and aim for the head
shinichi charges that pretty boy and
Dodges his attacks until he cuts off his
head but that's when they see the most
sickening and disheartening thing pretty
boy's head begins to merge back with his
body and they discover that pretty boy
is a parasite known as goto an
experimental parasite that was created
by them and has the powers of five
parasites in one body okay this is
insane because what these guys have
encountered is something more terrifying
than any alien they've ever seen before
this alien is called goto and remember
that ryoko girl who was low-key a mad
scientist well she basically created
this monster in a lab and this man has
five different parasites in his body and
he can use all five of their powers at
the same time pretty boy that we saw
earlier was just one of the parasites
taking lead in this body but now that
the gateau parasite is taking control of
this body SHINee she's about to be in
huge trouble and goto having five times
the parasites and his body means that by
default he has five times the bloodlust
and the desire to kill every human he
sees and he's many times smarter than
the average parasite making this guy the
perfect killing machine and one force
that chinichi and Miki here cannot
possibly stop they gotta run goto also
has the ability to adapt his parasite to
the environment being able to change his
hands and feet to Claws and long
cheetah-like legs this means that these
two being within this tree line makes
them severely at risk of being killed
due to koto's ability to climb and get
around the trees faster than they can
run away at least in the forest however
I do want to point something out while
Koto was changing his Consciousness
after having his head get cut off Megan
shinichi just sat there like two Chumps
and migi gave us the rundown exposition
of what this guy is he could have just
told us about this as we ran away in
reality migi could have explained all of
this later and the two of them could
have used the extra time that they had
to get away further for an Alien
Parasite migi's incredibly smart but he
right now isn't The Brightest Bulb in
this basket don't come at me weebs you
know I'm right Miki tells shinichi that
he will die if he tries to fight him and
knowing that they can't beat him they
run and hitch a ride on this truck to
escape they take a breather and think
they're safe but that's when they see in
the distance gutow chasing them down at
horrifying speed he grabs onto the side
of their truck and migi attempts to make
the truck driver crash into incoming
Vehicles this knocks Kato off and onto
the road and shinichi and migi managed
to escape for now later shinichi arrives
back into town and changes his clothes
to blend in knowing that the parasites
will come for everyone he loves he calls
his dad and tells him to leave town for
a while or else elsewhere the parasite
committee comes together to tell ryoko
the most horrifying thing and they tell
her that they managed to kill the
investigator's family since he knew too
much ryoko gets angry and tells them
that this will cost them big and that
they've been attracting too much
attention however the parasites suspect
that ryoko has gone too soft on the
humans ever since her host body gave
birth to a baby and they decide that she
needs to be killed ryoko then heads back
home but that's when she finds herself
surrounded by some of the parasites from
the committee and they've come to kill
her ryoko then escapes into this
construction site at her Killers follow
behind her this one chick tries to come
at her but ryoko brutally infects her
with her parasite which causes her to go
mad and ryoko runs off again one of the
other parasites try to follow her but
thinks that he has lost his mind this
causes him to head back to his parasite
group to figure out what's going on but
coming back he discovers that one of his
friends has become infected with ryoko's
parasite and he decides to put her out
of her misery he then realizes that this
was all a part of ryoko's plan just as
she suddenly shows up and brutally
dismembers him killing him and part of
the parasite committee for good later
ryoko goes home and finds out that her
baby has been taken by the investigator
with a note telling her to meet him in
the park she then heads to shinichi's
house to look at shinichi's baby
pictures and she calls shinichi from his
home phone and shinichi freaks out and
thinks that his dad is in trouble but
she tells shinichi that she's not
planning to harm him and tells him to
meet her in the same park as the
investigator so she can give him an
undisclosed package however on the way
to the park shinichi's second High
School crushed satomi sees ryoko come
out of shinichi's house and decides to
follow her at the park ryoko finally
arrives to see the investigator holding
her baby he tells her that she cost him
everything and wants revenge for his
family he tries to throw the baby off
the edge but gets stabbed through the
body by ryoko and she saves the child
about to die the investigator is shocked
and realizes that ryoko an Alien
Parasite actually cares for a human and
he falls off the Edge just then the
police reached the investigator's
mangled body and they tell him that they
were tracking him he then tells the
detective that a girl named ryoko did
this to him that his blood and DNA is on
her baby shortly thereafter he died
nearby shinichi finally arrives at ryoko
tells him that she's discovered that
parasites don't need to feed on humans
to survive and that there is a way for
both species to peacefully coexist with
each other she also warns shinichi that
the man he fought earlier today goto is
the most horrifying parasite to ever
exist and to avoid him at all costs
suddenly the police arrive and see ryoko
holding a baby with blood on its clothes
just like the investigator said not
wanting more people to die glasses guy
police chief here isn't taking any
chances and whips out his gray matter
Blaster firing at ryoko and horrifying
his men however realizing that this
mother with a baby is a parasite the
rest of the police join in to try to
kill her ryoko then protects the child
and she begins walking to shinichi
getting closer and closer to him and the
Police Stopped firing and migi suspects
that this might be a trap but shinichi
goes with his gut and discovers that
ryoko wants shinichi to take care of the
child and then she collapses in front of
everyone and dies shocking everyone here
whoa this is a big deal what ryoku just
did here was huge she just showed us
that these alien monsters are capable of
higher thought and by this I don't mean
that these aliens aren't self-aware
because they clearly are but ryoko's
actions here and protecting another life
form that wasn't her own shows that
these alien parasites are more complex
than we thought people like shinichi and
big mouth are case example of what
happens when the human brain isn't taken
over by a parasite and these two display
to us how the human consciousness and
the Alien Parasite can eventually find
ways to coexist within the same body but
in this case ryoko here was a full-on
parasite from the start her parasite
clearly infected this human host and
took over its brain meaning that the
actual human that ryoko inhabited wasn't
in control since the beginning this
means that within the cognitive
structure of a parasite or at least
while they're fully embedded within the
human host there is some sort of
mimicked response within their system to
show empathy and compassion towards
others and it was obvious that ryoko not
only cared for this human child but
protected it till the end that means
something this could mean that the
parasites despite their programming to
take over human brains are still
susceptible to inheriting their human
host's behavior as after all they're
inhabiting a human brain to begin with
now while this also could mean that
ryoko felt compassion for her child
since her host purposely tried to
conceive that child which means the only
reason she acted the way she did was due
to her host's maternal instincts
overpowering her alien brain after it
gave birth interfering with the
parasite's control but regardless this
is a huge sign and one that shinichi
should use to find out if parasites can
really be influenced by their host's
natural biological tendencies in some
way because at the end of the day
despite them being an alien they are
using human Tech as in their bodies to
survive meaning there likely could be a
way to exploit their weaknesses however
shinigi already being under the
magnifying lens of the police means that
he should be very careful about how he
talks about parasites with the
government as they'll likely turn him
into a lab rat if they find out his
experiment instead if I was I would play
dumb with the government but later send
them an untraceable letter male or some
sort of an anonymous account revealing
everything we know about parasites about
ryoko to the police this could allow
them to get the edge on the parasites
and put ryoko's body to good use since
at this right they'll likely never find
out [ __ ] about these monsters because it
will take too long to gain the upper
hand shinichi and migi are stunned at
ryoko's actions and they wonder why
didn't she choose to run or fight back
this whole time just then satome arrives
at the scene and sees shinichi crying
and showing human emotion for the first
time in a long while later the police
bring shanichi and his dad into this
laboratory for questioning bringing him
into this waiting room they mentioned
that since shinichi seems to attract
parasites wherever he goes maybe he can
sense them and even help the police
track their kind down but shinichi has
no idea that all of this is a horrifying
trap next door the police ask this guy
who claims to be able to tell parasites
from humans and they ask him if he can
figure out if these people are Paris
sites are not creepy face then begins
going through them clearing them one by
one until shinichi enters the room and
they ask shinichi if the prisoner in
front of him is secretly a parasite but
shinichi says that he's not sure he
begins to freak out inside and tries to
calm himself down but across from him
through the glass this detective wonders
if this kid is more involved with the
parasites than he seems suddenly creepy
face senses something within shinichi
and looks at him dead in the eye the
police hold their breath and think for a
sec that maybe shinichi is actually a
parasite but because migi is sleeping
creepy face isn't able to detect any
alien body inside of shinichi creepy
face then says that he's made a mistake
and that shinichi is not a parasite
saving shinichi for now elsewhere goto
meets with his minions and they tell him
that more and more parasites are
beginning to die that the Japanese
government has started to treat the
Alien Invasion more seriously even
creating a specialized task force to
deal with them and these monsters
prepare to brutally further everyone
soon the next day the specialized task
force shows up to this building a known
hangout spot for parasites and they
surround the place and they tell
everyone on loudspeaker to gather near
the entrance outside the police chief
ass creepy face to use his sensing
powers to help the police and tell who
is a parasite in that room along with
shinichi but both of them say that they
can't tell the police chief then tells
his men to ready their x-ray sensors
right near the exits of the building and
they wait for the people to come out the
new mayor of the city inside of this
building then tells the police to
evacuate the people most in need first
and groups of people begin to exit the
building while the police secretly try
to figure out who looks human and who
doesn't suddenly they spot this one
parasite through the x-ray scanners and
immediately kill it the leader of the
police force Commander stud face then
tells his men to bring over creepy face
to use his powers on these people but
that's when these humans then transform
into horrifying aliens killing this one
cop and the rest shoot these two dead on
site however they then discovered that
they've accidentally shot the sensing
system and now they can't tell Paris
sites from humans Commander stud face
then reveals that his plan was to never
save anyone but to kill the parasites at
all costs he and his men walk into the
building and begin killing anyone who
doesn't listen to them suddenly they get
word that some parasites have fled into
the building and he and his men split up
to find them bringing a long creepy face
creepy faces group then encounters one
of the parasites but that's when he
realizes who this parasite is goto
creepy face runs for his life and this
cop runs after him the soldiers then
follow Koto as he leads them into this
killing room and they prepare to fire
but that was their biggest mistake
suddenly they start firing but quickly
realize that Koto has absorbed all of
their bullets and he fires right back at
the soldiers killing everyone here one
by one in a horrifying blood path okay
this whole thing is a [ __ ] show because
while we can all admit that the
commander stud face pulls off a
three-piece suit better than those dudes
from peaky blinders he greatly
underestimated these parasites scum and
despite their already being a bloodbath
it's going to get a whole lot worse
because from the get-go he assumed that
these horrifying creatures were
simple-minded monsters that were easy to
exterminate like rats and he even had
shinichi on standby outside for the sole
purpose of helping out but Commander's
stud face even then continued to
disregard what shinichi told him about
flamethrowers being a weakness of these
parasites and he thought his team was
more hot [ __ ] than they really were
knowing that they were up against the
race of Unknown Origin from Outer
freaking space it's not inconceivable to
imagine that they could have used any
Edge they could have gotten and they
already know that these creatures are
batshit crazy so using batshit crazy
tactics and weaponry might be just what
they should have done to use to combat
these things but what makes this all the
more terrifying is that these guys win
in all gung-ho and assumed they knew
what they were up against but when you
think about how these creatures are
designed to evolve from entering the
Earth's atmosphere to adapting their
body to live within a human host it
makes sense that over time these
parasites rapid Evolution could mean
that some of these individual creatures
would evolve into being more deadly than
others and these are creatures at the
end of the day designed to survive at
all costs Commander stud face and his
team should have assumed that the exact
powers and ranks of the parasites were
variables that they couldn't control or
properly predict and they should have
been more careful and more ready to
expect the unexpected especially after
their initial plan during the first
phase Kana was a major flop killing the
parasites at any cost while badass and
theory was stupid and means that he
unnecessarily cost the lives of all of
his men and while I do love this
meaningless bloodbath Commander stud
Face's stupidity makes him Unworthy of
having such a badass name and also his
badass three-piece suit he's not worthy
of either of them Commander stud face
then gets notified that a part of his
team has been wiped out by goto he tells
the rest of his men to come around from
the other side of the building to try
and trap him nearby the police cornered
the mayor of the city they discovered
that he wants to use the parasites to
exterminate the weak people of the world
and to make the human race stronger but
the police kill him however they thought
he was a parasite but the man was in
fact human got and enters the room
pissed as hell and prepares to brutally
kill everyone here just outside
Commander stud face and his man arrive
just to see gotel walk out of the room
full of corpses they shoot at him but he
Dodges every attack and rips everyone
here to shreds horrified Commander stud
face makes his men Retreat to the roof
but Kato's super speed catches up to his
men and he kills the rest of them on the
way leaving behind only Commander stud
face and goto finally decapitates him
killing the entire force once and for
all nearby shinichi comes out to see the
katoa's throne Commander stud Face's
head into the bushes he's horrified
Justice goto jumps down and sees him
pissed off that he's here he tells
shinichi that he will now die before the
week's end and then he runs off before
more police show up shinichi later then
begins to lose his mind and thinks could
toes everywhere he looks he runs to the
park to calm himself down just as he
sees satomi seeing him worried she
invites him back to her empty house and
tries to help out some of shinichi's
worries the next day thanks to satomi's
Wizardry shinichi much now greatly
relieved realizes that he's gotta stop
Hotel no matter what it takes suddenly
migi alerts him to Koto is nearby and is
approaching them fast they quickly steal
a car and try to escape outside of town
Miki has an idea and they try to run
their car into Kato off the cliff but
they quickly realized that this monster
is Unstoppable with one last idea of his
sleep migi tells shinichi to retreat
into the forest and that's where Miki
breaks apart his alien body all over the
trees and shinichi hides nearby now
unable to sense where shinichi is Koto
tries looking for him but that's when
migi distracts him allowing shinichi to
throw a flamelit spear right into his
leg this causes goto's cells and his
body to become unstable and ride then
migi uses this moment to try and cut off
his head but that was his biggest
mistake migi realizes that he's failed
to properly cut off koto's head and with
no backup plan left migi tells shinichi
to run as he tries to hold goto off
shinichi is horrified as he runs away
migi being a part of shinichi's body for
so long eventually dies later that night
shinichi how exhausted arrives at a
nearby town and gets caught trying to
steal some some water from this Grandma
feeling sorry for him oh the lady
Grandma let shinichi stay the night as
he goes to sleep he wakes up in horror
and realizes that a part of migi's DNA
is still inside of him seeing his eye
pop out from his arm before disappearing
again and then Shanita and Grandma Bond
over the next few days and blah blah
blah she takes a break from his alien
fighting life but he doesn't realize
that the people around him are about to
die suddenly a mob shows up outside of
Grandma's house and complained that a
horrifying murder has taken place inside
the village they think Outsider shinichi
might know something about it and this
witness says that he saw a terrifying
creature out in the forest last night
kill his friend shinichi realizes that
Koto has arrived in this Village and it
won't be long before gotel finds him and
tries to kill him okay this is
terrifying because while shinichi did
well to run away when he was out of
options he's royally screwed up this big
time retreating to a nearby Village to
rest when he was critically injured was
the advisable thing to do for the night
however staying there for longer than
that after he was all healed up was
stupid as hell he got complacent and did
with all anime protagonists do after
they get the ship eat out of them by the
big villain he thought he could forget
about it all he thought he could forget
about the murderous alien on his ass
wrong oh he was very wrong because we
know that shinichi couldn't have gotten
far as he left the area where Koto was
during the day and arrived at the
Village seemingly at night after his
wizard session with satomi if you know
what I mean that it was between the late
morning to early afternoon when shinichi
got word from migi the Koto was on his
way to kill him and we can also assume
that the drive they took into the force
took around a few hours at minimum since
the train surrounded the village where
grandma lived seemed to be vastly
different to the city from which
shinichi just came from and since the
blood on shinichi's face still looked
fresh we can also assume that shinichi
reaching Grandma's house happened in
mere hours after he ran away from goto
this means that shinichi didn't travel
no distance for Jack's [ __ ] plus him
being injured didn't help and the only
reason that goto didn't catch up with
him to begin with was likely because he
was critically injured thanks to migi
nearly decapitating his head and due to
the injury his self took whichinichi
impaled him with that flameless spear
means that he likely needed time to rest
and repair before trying to hunch Nichi
down again shinichi covered far less
grounds than he should have and led
complacency get the best of him meaning
that whatever [ __ ] storm is about to
kick him in the face he totally deserves
the old fossil of the lady tries to stop
shinichi from leaving to take on the
monster but shinichi tells her that he
needs to finish what he started unable
to convince him she lets shinichi take
one of her knives and he heads out to
stop gato once and for all heading out
deep into the forest he finally spots
the terrifying goto but he's asleep
without much of migi left inside of him
she need to realizes that Koto can't
sense his presence he creeps up behind
him and prepares to strike but suddenly
Koto wakes up and knocks him back now
horrifyingly Angry kotel begins looking
for shinichi as he tries to think of a
new plan seeing this Spike he hides in
this tree and he tries to surprise
attack him but fails Matic hotel for
Mickey's death shinichi tries to punch
him but gets knocked back a final time
into this pile of trash now bleeding
from his mouth and kotel fast
approaching him he thinks of one last to
move he spots this Rusty pipe grabbing
it he bum rushes goto and manages to
stab him near his weak point in between
his armor however he realizes that his
cut wasn't deep enough and this makes
Koto even more angry now out of options
shinichi prepares to die and Koto tries
to brutally kill shinichi but that's
when migi suddenly blocks his attack and
absorbs goto's entire arm onto
shinichi's body migi is alive oh that
was stressful Koto is horrified as his
body begins to become unstable migi then
reveals that the rusty pipe that
shinichi stabbed him with had toxins
laced onto it from the trash pile and
now that five parasites encato's body
are sensing the toxins they're trying to
escape from his body now unable to
control his body anymore his body begins
to explode as migi deals the final
strike and makes him blow up however he
tells shinichi that if they don't finish
the job goto will soon regenerate and
come back to life knowing this shiniti
destroys the last bits of Kato's
destroyed body killing him for good and
the two head back into town to return to
their old life one year later as
shinichi migi and his dreams tells him
that he'll leave shinichi and go into a
form of hibernation for an unspecified
amount of time waking up shinichi
realizes that his right hand has become
fully human again saddened by the loss
of Meek he tries to continue on with his
normal life sanskato's death all the
parasite attacks have seemingly stopped
worldwide but shinichi thinks that these
terrifying monsters have finally managed
to blend into society for good hiding
within their hosts later while out on a
walk with satomi shinichi runs into none
other than creepy face he abducts satomi
and takes her onto this roof he reveals
two shinichi that he knew about his
parasite Powers all along and demands
that he reveal his secret to him and
satomi terrified at the idea of his
girlfriend learning his secret shinichi
tries to distract creepy face but that's
when he throws satomi off of the roof
shinichi rushes to try and save her
knocking out creepy face as he manages
to barely save her sweet life and now
he's finally become less of a loser now
thanks to migi and shinichi finally
becomes his own man and turns into the
stud muffin of his own story once and
for all but what what did you guys think
about the video don't forget to like
subscribe leave a thumbs up down below
let us know what you like about it what
you didn't like about it and as always
don't forget to check out our social
media and our how to beat anime after
show coming this Thursday